pretty good. Thank you for asking.
>> Uh so to begin this, I'd like to just,
you know, cuz I was in the comment
section and I was hearing a lot of
things and I would just like to debunk a
lot of the things that they were saying
because most people come up on here, you
know, make comments about Islam and they
actually have zero logic and they don't
know anything about it.
>> The earlier guy that you were telling
him, you know, he should go study the
Bible, etc., etc. It's that's why I was
um requesting to join up so much because
in my Islamic school back then they also
actually lessons from then. So they
would give us the Bible, they would give
us the Quran and they would tell us do
research on both come back tell me what
you learned and tell me which one makes
sense to you based off logic. Right?
>> So from a young age I was given both
books at when I was like seven eight.
And when I went back home, my mom told
me, "Yo, start with the Bible first so
there won't be any so you won't have any
bias in your mind." Right?
>> So I started with the Bible and first
thing is
>> to a seven to a seven, eight year old
kid, I opened the Bible and it started
talking about the trinity. Right?
>> Where
>> it said father son
>> I was seven I can't remember
>> you can't remember but as soon as
soonact hold on as soon as you open the
bible it was talking about the trinity.
Not as soon as I opened it, but not they
gave me a Bible and they told me to do
research on it. It wasn't as soon as I
opened it.
>> Okay.
>> Can I speak without being interrupted,
please?
>> Well, you're you're you're trying to
give me your life story. I'm I'm trying
to get into the topics here, brother.
>> All right. Bet. Let's let's get into the
topic then.
>> All right.
>> You do. Okay. So, I'm going to start
here. It says that so for example in the
um so I read about the Christianity and
all that and it told me that like oh
there's a trinity the father son holy
spirit right
>> the topics are Islam is false Quran
confirms the bible these are the these
are the topics on the page
>> it says I'm getting to that no
>> oh okay cuz you as soon as like it says
Islam is false Quran confirms the Bible
and then you immediately reference the
trinity again
>> the Quran when did the Quran confirm the
Bible
um in the seventh century
>> when quote the verse.
>> Oh, that's what you wanted. The verse.
Um
>> yeah,
>> you got uh chapter 3 verse 3 and 4.
>> Okay. What does it say?
>> It says, "We sent down the book in truth
confirming that which came before it,
and we revealed the Torah and the Gospel
of Time as guidance for mankind."
>> What's the context? The context is
Allah, you know, affirming that he sent
revelation.
>> Firstly, it doesn't Firstly, it doesn't
say the Bible. It says in
>> we never said that Jes we never said
Jesus didn't get a book. Jesus did get a
book. The book that Jesus was given was
called Injio. And inio is the correct
word of God. We go to any Muslim in the
world and ask them do they believe in
Injio and they'll tell you yes. Because
inje was a book given to Jesus that
Jesus himself spoke to his companions
about itself. Right.
>> What does what does inje
is what the gospel was meant to be?
>> Is it? No, I'm asking what does the word
mean? What does the word inje mean?
>> It's an Arabic word. It just it means
gospel. It's an Arabic. If you translate
it to English after translations, it
means gospel.
>> Okay. It's actually not an Arabic word,
but that's that's that's okay. I
understand you. So, uh, it means gospel.
And you're saying that I don't You're
saying that the the Bible like what's in
the Bible doesn't contain
>> I'm going to I'm going to finish to
explain because you just quoted one
word. You just quoted The thing is like,
>> do you know the thing is like
>> what what do you think the Bible is
user?
>> What
>> what do you think the Bible is?
>> I do believe that the Bible was actually
the word of God, but it got corrupted
down the line.
>> Okay. So you believe that the
>> I want to ask you just ask you this. I
want to ask you this.
>> One second. One second. One second.
Let's let's we got to go slow for this,
you know.
>> So you you do believe that the Bible is
a compilation or at least used to be a
compilation of
>> then it got corrupted. Yes.
>> Okay. So it was a compilation of Allah's
words but then it got corrupted.
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So when I say the it's confirming
the Bible when we see the Quran saying
that it confirms the book alab that is
with the Jews and Christians or the
psalms the gospel right the prophets
that's what the Bible is together okay
so it confir it so the Quran confirmed
the Bible it confirmed the Bible when it
says it confirms the Torah
>> confirmed the gospel
>> it didn't only That's the thing the
Bible in Islam there were many books
given before the reason and about 25
prophets. So let's go back right 25
prophets are mentioned in Islam and a
lot of prophets Ibraim was given a book
>> Moses was given a book Jesus was given
they were all given books but the reason
why Muslims do not believe in those
books anymore is because down the line
every single one of those books become
became corrupted. That is why the
prophet happened. Isn't it keep coming?
>> Isn't it part of the six principles to
believe in the revelation of Allah? The
press the past books,
>> the past books,
>> isn't it? Yeah. Isn't it one of your
principles of your faith that you have
to believe in the previous scriptures?
>> Principles or pillars? Which one do you
mean?
>> There's two there's two different
things. There's the five pillars and
then you have the six principles or the
six articles of faith of Islam.
I'm still stuck on the fact that he said
he first opened the Bible, he
immediately saw the Trinity. Amen to
that.
>> As soon as I opened the Bible, I said
that when I got home and I had the Bible
and I was studying over time, the thing
that stood out to me the most was the
Trinity. Because it's like this, right?
No, you don't you don't have to explain
it. You don't have to explain it. Just
just stay focused. I'm sorry. I I didn't
mean to throw you off. So, the six part
of the six principles, one of the six
>> So, the five pillars of Islam, not the
pillars, not the five pillars, not the
five pillars. The six principles. Have
you heard of the six principles of
Islam?
>> Yes, it is. Yeah,
>> I do know about those. Yeah, it's
>> it's to um believe in the holy books is
a part of them.
>> Yeah. So if you're saying that Muslims
now don't believe in the holy books,
then you're going against your religion.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on. When it says
holy books, right, it does not
necessarily say the Bible when it's
talking about holy books. Let me
explain.
>> Why? Why? Why do we have Why do we have
to do this? Why Why do we have to do
this, brother? Let's
>> No, let me explain. Let me explain. When
it's talking about
>> Let's be honest, man. Look, if you if
you want to if you don't want to say
Bible people
>> brother brother look just for the sake
of time and so that we don't know waste
time here
>> forget the word Bible because that's
just
>> okay
>> forget the word Bible the Torah Psalms
gospel the scriptures of the past of the
past prophets you're supposed to believe
in those right
>> we're supposed to believe that they were
revealed not to believe the stories they
tell
>> no the corrupt Wow
>> I don't think no let me let me speak
because this is the thing you don't
understand
you don't understand it and then you
just come in and then you speak off like
quoting one line without having the
context.
>> You're saying that I don't you're saying
that I don't understand this stuff but
I'm the one who had to show you what the
six principles of Islam were. Bro, I'm
I'm helping you, man.
>> I know what the six principles are.
>> Okay. So, I need to show you what the
Quran you're what you're saying is
opposite of what the Quran is.
>> Show me the Quran, my friend.
>> Why not?
>> I've I've read the Quran three times.
You can no one on this planet can show
me the Quran. So, so that so you reading
the you read the Quran three times and
you fixed your mouth to say that the
Quran that you're not supposed to
believe in the in the scriptures, but
you're supposed to believe that they
were revealed.
>> Listen, this is the thing. You just keep
talking over me without understanding.
>> I'm talking I'm listening to you. What
are you talking about?
>> When can I speak?
>> Yes. Just be direct.
>> Thank you. When it says believe in the
holy scriptures, it does not say believe
in the word inside of them. It says,
"Believe that they were revealed."
That's what it means
>> when it says, "Hold. I'm I'mma repeat
what you said. I'm I'm repeating it."
Wait, relax. That's it. Relax. I think
that's it. Doesn't
>> We're doing You're doing good. Let's
Let's walk through this. Trust me.
>> All right.
>> We're all listening very intently and
carefully.
When the Quran says, and ladies and
gentlemen, make sure y'all, Matter of
fact,
I gotta write this down.
Where is my super pen, honey?
Where is my super pen?
>> One second. Sorry.
>> I don't know.
>> You don't know? I don't have it.
>> Where? Why would you touch my super pin?
>> I didn't take it.
>> But the world is in trouble. I'm trying
to reach this Muslim.
>> Let me find you.
>> Find me my super pin.
Sorry. She's uh she's going to get it.
>> Can I speak without being interrupted,
please?
>> If I can.
>> And like without you I don't know.
>> Sorry, brother.
>> I'm I'm sorry, man. Um if you're if you
take offense to me smiling and laughing,
I'm a very light-hearted person. I don't
mean any disrespect to you as an
individual.
>> I don't take I'm not taking offense to
talking.
>> All right. Good. So So we're good. So
you don't have to ask me not to laugh.
Let's we're I'm a human being.
>> I didn't say not to laugh. I said, "Can
I speak without being interrupted?"
>> Do you hear yourself, bro?
>> Can I speak without being interrupted?
>> You You didn't hear yourself just say,
"Can I can Can you speak without being
interrupted and for me not to laugh?"
You didn't just you didn't hear yourself
say that.
>> Can I please speak, bro?
>> Goodness. Just hold just hold on. Hold
on. Wait.
>> We're meant to be having a debate. I
don't get what why we're wasting time on
this. Honestly,
>> because you're making claims that waste
our time.
>> No pen over there, sweetheart. It's
okay.
It's all right. You can shut the door.
It's okay. I'll just 100 remember it. We
We'll We'll remember it.
Oh man. Okay. So look um
um um um what was Oh yeah. So you said
that the Quran when the Quran says to
believe in those scriptures in what was
revealed to not believe in the words.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> Not to believe in the words but just
believe that they were revealed. Is that
right?
>> Can I elaborate on what I said?
Absolutely. Go ahead. Go ahead. Break
it. Break it down for us. Break it down.
>> So, the Quran says, "Believe in the holy
scriptures." Right?
>> When it says that, it's basically
telling us that believe that these
scriptures were revealed to these
prophets.
It doesn't say believe exactly what is
inside of them. Because if it says that,
then the other point it made about every
the only reason and let me explain
again, right? The only reason that a
prophet kept on coming after and after
and after was because when one prophet
came with a certain word, it got
corrupted and then another one had to be
sent down. Do you understand? So when I
get back and like you say that the Quran
confirms, you know, the existence of
>> You just made a point.
>> I got to respond to that.
>> You said you said the Quran. Wait, let
me finish. You said I'm not
>> even that you finish. You're you're now
going to another point. I have to
address what you just said. You said the
it's in the same thing. Let me just
finish. Okay,
>> bro. I'm going to give you I'm going to
give you I'm I'm going to say this right
now, bro.
>> You just said made a point and you
begged me to let you make that point.
You made the point. Now you're trying to
make another one. I'm going to respond
to what you just said.
>> If you have a problem with that, then I
I can bring up the next person. I'm not
in a I'm not in a mood for all this this
whining, this crying. Let's talk like
human beings, like men. When you make a
point, I'm gonna listen to you and I'm
gonna respond to that point. Sounds
good. Or should I move on?
>> Okay. So, you just made a point.
>> So, according to your point, you said
that the Quran says not to believe in
the words of those scriptures, but just
simply believe that they were revealed
once upon a time. Now, what I want you
to do is give me a verse that says what
you said.
>> It's what it means. It doesn't have it's
there's a hadith that explains it.
>> There's a hadith that Awesome. Nice.
There's a hadith that explains it. The
verse doesn't say what he said, but it's
what it means.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Go ahead. Go ahead. Take
take your time. Get the hadith. Let's
see what the hadith says, cuz I I'm
going to need something, bro. I can't
just, you know, trust you, bro.
I can't just trust you, bro.
Give me a second.
>> All the time you need. Um, in the
meantime, I'm just going to go ahead and
read some super chats. When you get the
source, just let me know. Hey, Avery,
I'm back with the source. Okay? Just let
me know. Um, I'm going just read some
super chats in the meantime.
All right. Um,
uh, you guys are having too much fun
here. All right. We got a super chat
from Luis who says, "Glory to our Lord
Jesus Christ." Amen to that. Our only
Lord and Savior. Amen. Amen.
SJ says, "By the way, Sam's question to
Jabir was, if the Quran is de a detailed
explanation of all things, then who was
Ibrahim's wife?" Jabir replied, "Which
one?"
>> All right, I'm already back. I'm already
back.
>> Awesome.
>> I'm already back.
When the Quran says, "Believe in the
holy scriptures, eg Torah, Psalms,
Gospel," right? It's referring to the
original revelations Allah sent to
earlier prophets to reveal to
>> not what you said.
>> Let me speak. Brother,
>> that is exactly what I said,
>> brother. You have a problem with your
word. Look, I look I'm telling you this
is recorded. It's on my YouTube channel,
God Logic Apologetics. As Listen,
>> no, I'm I'm crazy right now. I know you
are what I said.
>> I know. Listen, as a fellow human
brother from a human brother to another
human brother, watch the clip back and
you'll see you never that wasn't your
problem. Your your claim your claim was
not that oh you need to believe in the
original scriptures. Your your claim was
when it says believe in what was
revealed means not to believe in the
words of those books but to believe that
they were revealed once upon a time. But
you don't got to believe in the words
themselves. That's what you said. And
then you said, "Wait, wait, wait, wait."
And then you said, "User, that you were
going to give me a hadith that says that
because the verse doesn't say it."
>> So you said you was going to bring me
the hadith. Do you have the hadith that
says that?
>> Do you have the
>> Can I speak?
>> Yeah. Do you have the hadith that says
that?
>> Can I speak?
>> Do you or do you not have the hadith
that says what you said?
>> Can I speak? I'm gonna give you one last
chance. You asked me if you can speak
again. You're done.
>> Thank you.
>> You need to give me the hadith like what
you just said. Do you or do you not at
this moment
>> have the hadith that says you don't have
to believe in the words of the
scripture, but just believe that they
were revealed once upon a time. Do you
have the hadith that says that?
>> I might have mixed it up. It was
actually in the Quran.
>> Okay. All right. Back and forth, back
and forth, back and forth. I can leave
you a verse.
>> I'm waiting. Go ahead. Go ahead. I'm
waiting. Go ahead. Get the verse.
>> All right. I can give you a verse. Okay.
>> Sure. Get that back.
>> Surah al surah al bakar chapter 2 verse
284. Right.
>> Okay.
>> The messenger
has believed in what was revealed to him
from his lord and so have the believers.
All of them have believed in Allah, his
angels, his books and his messengers.
Right? Says surah al bakar 2 verse 136.
Right?
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. You just Let's talk about
the verse one, one at a time, and trust
me, I'm going to let you bring up
whatever verses you have. We're going to
go one by one. Okay?
>> So, 284. Now, I'mma test your honesty.
>> 285.
>> 285. Sorry. I'mma test your honesty.
>> No. 2 verse 8.
>> Two verse 284, right?
>> 285. Got it.
>> 85. 85. So
I'mma ask you this question and user I
need you for the sake of this argument
and for the sake of the audience
listening I need you to be honest with
the answer.
>> Okay.
>> Does that verse say
that you are not to believe in the words
of those books but only that those books
were revealed once upon a time?
>> It doesn't explicit. It doesn't say to
believe in the word, but al it doesn't
say to not to believe in it, but it also
doesn't say to believe in it.
>> All right, do me this one favor.
>> It says neither.
>> Do me this one favor. Read the verse one
more time.
>> Okay. The messenger has the messenger
has believed in what was revealed to him
from his Lord and so have the believers.
All of them have believed in Allah, his
angels, his books and his messengers.
>> They believed in Allah, his angels and
his what?
his books and his messengers.
>> So according to the according to the
Quran, you're supposed to believe in the
books,
things that have words in them
>> that they were originally revealed.
Yeah.
>> Does it does it say that they were
originally revealed or does it just
simply say believe in the books?
>> Can I can I read Can I like cuz it's
like you allow you allow me to make a
half point without actually like
elaborating. That's the thing. I'm I've
been let letting you elaborate fully.
Does it say believe in the in Allah,
believe in the angels and the in in the
original books or does it simply just
say believe in Allah, believe in his
angels and believe in his books. Which
one does it say? Original books or just
books?
>> It says believe in both.
>> You said believe in both. Where where
does it mention original in the verse?
It says, "Believe in Allah, his angels,
his books, and his messengers."
>> So, does it say original books or does
it just say books in general?
>> It just said his books.
>> So,
>> that's the point. That's the point that
I'm trying to make. Listen, that's the
point that I'm trying to make. Yeah. Cuz
you keep like speaking over me, etc.,
etc.,
>> thinking that like you're making any
logic because you're not letting me make
spin.
>> Take Take care of yourself, man. I'm
done with your crying. I'm done with you
crying and wasting my time. You big cry
baby. You big baby. Oh.
Oh.
Is the little mini money m hurt?
The little mon couldn't speak.
The little mon need a bottle. You You
want some milk? You want some milk?
Little mon.
[Music]
I didn't let you speak, little mun.
I just You're right. I just let Allah
speak. I let Allah speak. And you wish
Allah didn't say it. You wish Allah
didn't say what you and not You can't
make this up. You went to the verse that
cooked you.
I didn't bring up that verse. You did.
Y'all see what happens when y'all let
the Muslims talk? when y'all let them
dig their own grave.
He was using one of those God logic
shovels, man. One of those God logic
shovels is one of them self-made
self-digging shovels.
It digs your It digs the graves. You
say, you know, you don't got to do it. I
You don't got to dig the grave of your
opponent. They'll do it for you. The
shovel will do the work for you.
Good gracious, you guys. Y'all can't
y'all y'all can't be serious. But I want
y'all to hear this. Did y'all hear this?
Muslims, are y'all okay with this? If
you guys are thinking about being
Muslim, are you okay? Is this what you
want to follow? Were you what? In order
to be a Muslim,
you have to lie
to stay a Muslim.
In order to be a Muslim and stay a
Muslim, you have to lie.
Notice what happened when I challenged
him to bring me what he's saying the
Quran says.
He made a point. I said, "Show me where
the Quran says that." Oh, well, uh, it's
not in the Quran. It's just what it
means. Oh, it's in the Hadith. Okay.
Show me the hadith where it says that.
Um, you know what? I mixed it up. It's
actually in the Quran. Okay. Shir says
that. Uh,
chapter 2 verse 285 says, "Believe in
the books." Ah, no. Stupid, stupid,
stupid. I should not have brought that
one. H,
man.